arguably more great goalkeepers play in
the bundesliga than in any other league
germany is known for producing huge
talents between the sticks
but there is something perverse about
the position
the goalkeeper was a specific type of
exile a scapegoat always handily there
to take the blame for the rest of the
team
it used to be that the goalkeeper was
the clumsiest kid on the playground the
one picked last when teams were divided
up
sports journalist jonathan wilson has
written a book about the history of the
position
the outsider offers an inside look at
the loneliest job in sport
keepers he says weren't always outcasts
the goalkeeper initially he was part of
the team he wore the same colored shirt
and although he could handle the ball he
was essentially just another player and
you look at the the very first rules in
1863 and there's no no reference to a
goalkeeper any player could handle the
ball could catch the ball and was
allowed a free kick now that changes
over the end of the 19th century and
finally in 1908 the goalkeeper was given
a different coloured shirt it takes
almost 50 years before he's really
pulled apart from the rest of the team
with the change of jersey goalkeepers
gained an identity and some of them
became stars gordon banks ricardo zamora
leviathan
tony turek
and bear troutman
i think trenton's story i mean it's one
of the most extraordinary stories not
just in football but one of the most
extraordinary stories of the 20th
century his experiences
uh you know in the war of becoming a
prisoner of war in england and then
adapting to english life and he was
really sort of the first popular german
after the second world war in england
and i think it says much about his
charisma and his personality and how
good he was as a goalkeeper not just not
only was he a great keeper but he was in
involved in one of the
most iconic moments
of the fa cup that he he broke his neck
near the end of a cup final and and
played on so he be you you sort of saw
the heroism
the possibility of becoming a hero or a
scapegoat distinguishes the keeper from
the rest of the team a few years back
kickoff talked to former u.s number one
casey keller about what qualities
goalkeepers need his answer was frank
stupidity of being a goalkeeper what
stupidity is it stupidity it's
it's not a fun
it's not a fun job sometimes you're part
of the team and sometimes you're not
part of the team
we train separately
most of the time
if a goalkeeper makes a mistake it tends
to be catastrophic it tends to cost a
goal if you're a full-back you can make
a mistake and maybe the winger messes up
the cross maybe somebody covers for you
you'll send it forward you miss a chance
you get another chance people forget
that if you're a goalkeeper you drop a
cross and somebody puts it in or you let
a shot slide under your body obviously
remember because it results in a goal
even one of the most formidable keepers
of all time the titan ollie khan new
moments of absolute despair
one mistake is all it takes for a
goalkeeper no matter how good to make
negative headlines
you have to have a robust psychology you
have to clean up everyone else's
mistakes and not get unduly distracted
by your own ones
sometimes goals simply happen it's part
of the game
but then everyone turns his back on you
because they have to go back to the
middle of the pitch
situations like that perhaps mess with
your subconscious so the goalkeeper kind
of has to be like a terminator
you could compare it with a surgeon
performing a difficult operation who's
completely drained after three or four
hours even though he hasn't exerted
himself physically the mental work is
very exhausting
and then there are the moments when the
referee blows his whistle his stony
demeanor brooks no objections as he
points to the spot
what follows is the ultimate showdown in
football
i think the penalty it breaks football
down into its absolute purest form
there's a man trying to score a goal
there's a ball there's a man trying to
stop him scoring a goal
and so
it's absolutely pure it's the essence of
football
goalkeepers in the relish penalties
because nobody expects them to save them
and the usual polarities are reversed
concede a penalty and it's one of those
things save one and you become a hero
an inversion of a goalkeeper's usual
role as a scapegoat
modern goalkeepers are also expected to
have good skills with their feet
and then i think that that takes an
another leap uh with the introduction
the back pass law in in 92 that from
then
goalkeepers have to be good with both
feet they they can't be people who
effectively can't kick the ball they've
got to be able to deal with the ball
being passed back to them and gradually
i think we've recognized that the
benefits goalkeepers can have they
dispute the ball well whether that be
with a long throw or a long kick i think
um certainly the last 10 years or so
there's probably no country has produced
so many good goalkeepers as germany and
manuel neuer
know he recently voted the best
goalkeeper in the world and i think very
few people would argue with that annoyer
i think is is a great example of this
this idea of the sweeper keeper somebody
who if the defense pushed out the back
four
pushed out somebody who could sweep up
behind to cut out the the risk of three
balls in that space um i remember
occasionally last euros the game against
italy as as germany were pushing up
desperately seeking the equalizer and
there's neuer in the center circle
heading the ball he's so far out of his
goal but you know totally confident
totally capable of doing that and
allowing the defense to push right up
but even neuer makes the occasional
mistake and when he does everyone is
quick to criticize
the life of a goalkeeper is uncertain
good goalkeepers have reputations
damaged by one unfortunate mistake
others are thrust into the limelight by
one or two saves there's a randomness
about it that is unsettling
bad things happen to good people and we
don't necessarily get what we deserve
goalkeepers may not get the recognition
they deserve but with your help we'd
like to recognize one member of the
german footballing family
you